[Applause]
[Music]
and meet your opponent draga
[Applause]
hey youtubers is Charlie so whole bunch
of comic-book stuff just happened on
Supergirl so I'm gonna explain what the
hell's going on in how quickly they'll
probably be able to get to doing
Warworld stuff most of you are asking
about the draaga Warworld shout out so
just like shooting the beam into the
multiverse like the beam of information
on the flash sounds like a really bad
idea just because who could pick that
beam up you know somebody who's really
intelligent maybe use someone who's
really dangerous
maybe Mongol will hear that Supergirl
defeated draaga his most prized champion
from war world in the comics his
interest is piqued and wants to add her
to his stable of fighters on war world
but the problem is is that Mongol this
is Mongol one not Mongol - you know very
creative naming your son Mongol - but it
just feels like what they're trying to
build towards in the four-night
crossover is the dominators in Mongol
war world is this whole level beyond
like what they've done so far that it's
just too much of a jump to do that this
quickly so what they might do you just
continue to tease that out because
they're doing so much alien stuff like
there are aliens who are using earth is
sort of a hideout the president of the
United States you know
Wonder Woman Lynda Carter here who is an
alien in disguise herself just gave
amnesty to aliens everywhere so of
course something from outer space is
going to come some big threat that is
beyond the dominators because here's the
thing
they've clarified that the four-night
crossover is mostly going to be
happening on the old-school CW shows
they're gonna have to go get Supergirl
because she's still on a different earth
and they're not going to combine her
earth with earth 1 anytime soon now they
didn't say they're not gonna do that
eventually but they did make it sound
like they're gonna keep her on a
different earth for now so they can do
like crazy war world stuff and they
don't have to deal with it on arrow in
the flash because I feel like the
problem with that is arrow it's trying
to be super grounded in war world Mongol
is like the least grounded thing you
could possibly do so there's just
certain types of stories that it's
really hard to do a
arrow goes off the air but you're all
asking about Miss Martian most of you
have probably seen a little bit of Young
Justice so you have a little bit of
familiarity with the character even if
you haven't read the comics so you can
kind of see what they're doing with her
character she's a little bit older she's
300 years old
on the TV show she's 48 years old on
Young Justice so on Supergirl
instead of having more parity with the
Supergirl character she has more parity
with the Martian Manhunter character and
like they had this big theme you know
Hatfields and McCoys in the episode
where they're kind of pairing characters
off so like very clearly Martian
Manhunter we'll get closer so they're
building towards the reveal where
Martian Manhunter finds out that she's a
white Martian and there's all that drama
but like Supergirl doesn't really know a
lot about her like the other characters
aren't super close with her so she's
mostly there for the benefit of Martian
Manhunter storyline so you know just
remains to be seen where they choose to
take her but eventually she'll probably
start working with the team the way
they're presenting them that they're
fairly equal in terms of power levels
and abilities but there are a few
differences Miss Martian is able to
mind-control other people whereas
Martian Manhunter is just telepathic so
we might not see something like that
happen unless she just totally goes off
the rails which i think is a shirt like
you know usually they don't tease
something unless they intend to do it
like of course her secrets gonna get out
when she loses control like the reason
Martian Manhunter
shifted during this big fight here is
because she almost knocked him the eff
out and he lost control so something
similar is gonna happen to her she's
gonna lose her [ __ ] and then she'll
shift into white Martian form and
everybody else will lose their [ __ ] so
the only other thing is MA Nell you guys
can let me know but but obviously I
think you know because they tease that
win is gonna make him a superhero
costume and give him a superhero name I
feel like what they'll do is they'll
give him the comic book costume like the
red costume with the cape but what they
might do is they'll either name him
valor like he was in the comics or
they'll name him Superboy
so just remains to be seen it's just
that problem is is that Superboy
technically should be Conner Kent but I
don't think they're gonna do Conner Kent
like the Lex Luthor clone Conner Kent
because this is more
supergirl show if it were a Superman
show and they had Lex Luthor on every
week I would definitely say Conner Kent
which is because of the characters
they're using I feel like it's less
likely that they would go with that
version of Superboy so you guys can let
me know what are they gonna call ma Nell
on the TV show will they call him valor
or will they just call him Superboy but
there's a new episode of the flash
tonight I'll post it after it airs so be
sure to subscribe to get that they've
been teasing savat are they said that
he's going to appear really soon but
they basically said yeah you won't have
to wait long he's coming really soon so
gay night is gonna be crazy
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here learn about the drama
that's going on with the flash movie and
you can click here for the trailer for
that flash episode thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight